clouded developer communities are groups
of like-minded cloud developers who get
together and regular basis and teach
each other learn from each other on new
cloud developer technologies when you
attend one of the Google cloud community
meetups you just can talk to people
about what you're doing your new project
and you'll also have the chance to talk
to experts and learn from them
you can also create some kind of
communication between different cloud
gdgs over around the world like we're
doing Tel Aviv together with London
it's amazing the impact that you can
give to the developer community as the
community is evolved and the products
evolve on topics also evolved with time
including more details or more
fundamentals of as new things get
launched we have people from Google
sharing experience with box chain from
the CCP it's very important for me to
starting something specific for Google
cloud because it's something new in
Brazil there's very diverse and that's
it's gonna be different
most of our activities are hands-on
where you come in and both of us and
participants go together to the code and
we run two exercises and get the results
Google cloud platform has been enjoying
amazing growth recently they give us
amazing feedback on what the products
really should be trying to make sure we
address the market as best as possible
[Music]